[Music]
chuck
yes i'm excited about this one i want to
talk about the moon okay
all right now there's a lot of these
where we talk about the moon but i want
to put it all in one place
at one time here and now all right that
sounds good
all right all right uh exist every
moon joke yeah every every mooning drive
i am yes
i'm right now i'm just putting myself in
the mental space
you stop thinking about butts and cracks
and all of that all of that moon okay
yeah
all right here we go all right so this
is mostly moon lore i just want to
put it all under one under one roof okay
oh i love it
so let's start out with the moon on
horizon illusion
you ever hear about that the moon on the
horizon no i don't know
oh so what it is it's what we call it
maybe you you
felt it you see the moon rising over the
city landscape or the mountain of course
and it's huge yes it's so beautiful it's
beautiful big giant yellow ball ball
right right and you don't have that
reaction when it's up overhead
no because it's a little yellow dot and
okay that's not
empty so so why does the moon feel
bigger on the horizon than
high in the sky it is it is not actually
bigger
at all okay you can measure it in fact
it's slightly smaller for other reasons
i'm not going to get into but
it so it's it's completely psychological
and so we call it the moon on horizon
illusion
nice yeah because your brain makes a
judgment at all times
how far away something is uh-huh it's
making this judgment okay
stereopsis based on that judd that's
yeah correct and based on that judgment
it will say here's how i big i think
that object
is right so think about it if you if you
look at
i'm getting a really stupid obvious
example if you look up in the sky
and you see an airplane you're not
saying to yourself oh the airplane's
only this big it can fit between my
fingers
you you're not saying that but you do
take your fingers
and hold it up and look make it look
like you're flying the airplane
like you know yeah i've never done that
chuck yeah
okay okay all right i'm sorry moving on
moving on sorry i've never done that
so maybe others have i don't know i just
personally i don't
believe i have to help the airplane
through the sky
and and i felt that way very early in my
life i didn't
so so you you know not only intuitively
but your brain is doing
subliminal calculations about how big
something would actually be
if it were right in front of you for how
small it is for how far away you see it
to be all right so the moon
as far as your depth perception is
concerned is basically at infinity
okay it's basically at infinity that
makes sense so
what happens is the moon shows up
in the company of terrestrial objects
you are familiar with
buildings mountains trees
you know how big those are oh okay
fascinating and then the moon is
hanging out with them and so your brain
is saying wait a minute
is that is it really there or is that it
no but
and while your brain is trying to figure
this out your brain starts thinking
the moon is huge huger than at any other
time
in the sky and by the way you said the
moon is yellow you know why it's yellow
when it's low on the horizon
uh i i mean i can only guess that it's
atmospheric
yeah exactly it's for the same reason
the sun is yellow on the horizon
the sun is an actual yellow it's yellow
on the horizon because the atmosphere is
affecting the color
and if you have a polluted sky it'll be
deeper and deeper deeper
from yellow into amber and maybe even
red so
you can get very sort of deep deep um
deep amber moon if it stays low point is
this is a moon on horizon illusion and
people say i saw such a big moon last
night i'm saying
no you didn't you only thought it was
big wow
that is so cool by the way so now
last point about the moon on the horizon
okay what's throwing off your
depth cues is the full moon mixed in
with other things that are familiar to
you as
i've already said correct okay if you
have the full moon rising
over a horizon for which you have no
depth cues
the effect is greatly diminished and in
fact it's hardly there at all
for example the moon rising at sea
i was going to say it on the over the
ocean over the open ocean there's no
trees there's no buildings
there's nothing so that that effect is
greatly diminished and you want to know
how to get rid of the effect
entirely here's what you do there's the
large moon on the horizon
next to buildings and things turn around
okay all right with your back to the
moon
okay bend over
and look at the moon upside down through
your legs
okay okay okay okay now
don't pull down your draws when you're
doing this because then you'll be
mooning the moon
okay but
if you do this then the building's on
the horizon and the trees are upside
down
and your brain says i don't know what
that is i don't want to upside down i
don't know what that
is oh so now i can put the moon where it
belongs at infinity and the moon becomes
its regular size
so the lack of reference causes your
brain
to see the moon the way it is instead of
causing it to make the association to
the size
of the things surrounding it correct
correct and so
so so and i invite you to do that
experiment next time the moon looks
suspiciously large on the horizon
just bend over bada-bing it goes right
back to its eyes
don't get two bada-bings and one and yes
you can
what are you doing well i'm looking at
the moon and kissing my ass goodbye
all right so more about the moon the
moon is always opposite
the full moon is all talk about the full
moon here it's always opposite the sun
all right that's because that's why it's
full it's it's full
frontal to the sun it's getting the full
reflection of the sun the full refund
from from our point of view on earth
okay so
uh because you mentioned the moon is
kind of yellowish on the horizon
yellowish amber
and i might have said this at another
time but here's a good place to reinsert
it
all right uh in the summertime
uh the sun is it takes this
very high arc across the sky okay
and then when the sun sets it takes a
very
low arc beneath the horizon because it
doesn't stay down there very long
well if it takes a low arc on the
horizon if you have full moon
the full moon we will be opposite it and
we'll also be in a low arc
okay so now watch so watch in the
summertime like in
june you know right june
when the full moon rises it stays
low in the sky really low doesn't get
very high at all
so if you if you had sort of sunset
colors on the moon right when it rose
and it doesn't get very high it's never
going to
free itself of the contaminating effects
the color contamination of the sky of
the of our atmosphere
so it'll it'll it'll come up it'll be
like deep amber but it's not going to
really ever not be
amber in that very low arc across the
sky
and then it sets all right wait a minute
the full moon in june stays low on the
sky
and it's and it holds on to those sort
of sunset
amber colors it takes on a kind of a
honey color
oh of all the moons of the year and they
all have names
the name of the full moon in june is the
honeymoon
the honeymoon what
bada bing that's sweet oh i feel like i
should be
doing something more with the moon so
i just wanted to bada bing the moon is
that allowed how many
bangs in the day do i get i don't know i
don't know if you get the body being the
moon
especially on the honeymoon the
honeymoon so every moon has a
has every full moon has a name you've
heard of some the harvest moon this sort
of thing
flowers yeah the flower and they're all
cultural
and regional by the way depending on
what mattered there's a wolf moon a snow
moon this sort of thing
so the blood moon is my favorite no
don't don't go there please
don't come on man why not no that's a
whole other explainer
no no just that's a different explainer
video
to back away from the term
put the term down on the table right and
step away
sir i'm gonna ask you one last time
put the blood moon down
all right all right maybe i should
should i slip it in here all right let
me slip it out
we might run out of time i don't know
okay all right uh do you know what the
blood moon is
i i i've heard of it i don't know what
it is well you're like
how are you talking about it you don't
know what it is dude because it's my
favorite term for the moon
okay so this is the term that some
people
invented to describe the full moon
during a lunar eclipse yes that's where
i heard it
okay so so a blood moon could then
happen at any time of the year
if there is a lunar eclipse okay and
what happens in a lunar eclipse
earth interposes itself
between the sun and the moon okay
so exactly interposes itself in such a
way that
it's like the moon is like yo hold me
back hold me back
and the sun is like you better hold him
back
cause i'm about to mess him up bad he's
like ladies and gentlemen
chuck is from philadelphia and the earth
is like guys
guys come on seriously guys
that's always what the person who's
stopping the fight sounds like why why
is the person stopping the fight oh wait
guys
guys come on guys come on guys seriously
it's never stop the fight
right no the person who sounds like that
never stops fights they start him
all right so watch what happens so we
are in space earth is
people say i want to go into space just
stand on earth you're in space all right
so earth is in space and there's a
shadow that's always there
cast by the sun okay now you have the
moon
orbiting the earth and occasionally the
moon will enter that shadow
blocking the light of the sun from the
fully illuminated moon
and we have a lunar eclipse a lunar
eclipse okay
so if you were to watch this from the
moon
you'll see this dark orb
move slowly and begin to blot out the
sun
okay the earth is much bigger than the
sun on the sky
all right so it is it the sun is lost
behind
the earth again let's watch this from
the moon now okay so now
here's what happens sunlight
tries to get around to the other side by
working its way
through earth's atmosphere right okay
so the light sort of disperses and and
refracts a little
almost like a filter or yeah it's
sometimes
but it's only around the edges because
the full disc
of the sun is blocked by the moon by the
right
so it's just light that's trying to work
its way around if you have a heavy
heavily polluted atmosphere okay then
that sunlight gets deeply reddened as
you'd have a deep red
sun on our settings at sunset right
right
would be on the horizon right just like
it would be on the horizon okay just
like it would be because the sun
technically is on the horizon for that
picture
all right so if you have a highly
polluted or it's over the sahara where
there's a lot of dust particles kicked
up
then it deeply reddens the sunlight that
leaks
around the earth and some of that spills
into earth's shadow
and so the moon which would otherwise be
completely blotted out
can take on a very deep sort of
amber better look ready ready ready
but okay that can happen
i saw it happen several times in the
1960s and early 70s
and i have not seen that happen since oh
we've been cleaning up the air of the
earth
because what makes the sun deeply red
people say oh that's beautiful look no
because air got particles in it okay
you're breathing pollutants you're
breathing particulates all right
so that's what's reddening the sun you
have less of that the sun is less red
in a lunar eclipse i've not seen a red
moon lunar eclipse
in 40 years oh but they say blood red
and plus it's not red it's like in deep
amber
all right it's not any more red than
someone who has red hair
you is it is it actually red no it's
more it's it's just rusted color
hold it up to a red is it that red no no
okay a little ginger kid you yeah so
what happens is people exaggerate the
color
of other people right all right and so
when they when they're being described
white people aren't purely white black
people aren't purely black we have a
word for
how much light you reflect it's called
albedo by the way
albedo so albedo of one means you
reflect all the light albedo of zero
means you're absorbable the light but
anyway
that's that's another explainer we'll
get to that so so
here's my point so that's how you would
get a red moon
or a and people want to say blood so
i've seen people who are very
taken by vocabulary by word a
blood red moon that means something bad
is going to happen just because somebody
misnamed it
doesn't mean you now have get to take
the word and create a whole
system of cultism around the word that
someone badly chose to describe an
object in the sky
well thank you for making me hate blood
moons now
it went from my favorite to the
worst i'm just saying so what will
happen is the moon gets eclipsed and
just basically disappears from the sky
in fact most people who have ever
witnessed a lunar eclipse didn't even
know
because it looks like you have a
crescent moon the earth's shadow is
curved
and it just looks like a crescent moon
and it gets a little dimmer and then it
just disappears completely
and then you don't even notice it until
it sort of re-emerges on the other side
so the a lunar eclipse is long and
boring and hardly noticed by anybody who
isn't looking for it
it's just a reality check don't don't
shoot the messenger all right
and it and it speaks so highly of you
chuck did i explain you out did you you
got any i'm done here no but i know
we're out of time
yeah we're out of time yeah that was
good
we're out of time so until next time i'm
neil degrasse tyson
keep looking up
you